second executive meeting of September
um I'll get scrapping so the Tendencies
I've had no apologies from the
initiative so if we move on to
Declarations of Interest which I've
received not and this evening we have no
questions from the public so at this
point I'm going to go to item four and
uh any Matters from overview overview
and scrutiny committee so I'll go to
council acting first
thank you
um yeah just do it yeah that didn't know
that we uh we held a meeting last week
there's five of the largest housing
associations who have profited in in the
forest to actually discuss how they are
tackling the problem of mold and down
following the current report on the
subset of the little boy in Rockstar
and members of the committee were able
to have searching questions and they did
ask 13 questions
Associated officers about what policies
they have to tackle the redempt
problems that they have in there having
to stop
and the Housing Association officers
responded
you know positively and I think it was a
good meeting in that way and openly and
set out their commitment to deliver on
ensuring that they do tackle the
problems
and clearly this council's like all
other councils across the country have a
duty to make sure that housing providers
whether they are housing associations of
private renters that they ensure that
homes are safe and put to a decent
standard and I think I was pleased that
James came on to that meeting and Adrian
Fisher and it was really helpful that
they they did
and as we know we have certain powers to
hold
them to account you know whether it's
private or whether they're having shares
however I think we need to look
carefully at the capacity of our
officers to be able to Monitor and
um you know whole uh the associations
and private have meant to do accounts I
think that's really important that is
our duty as a council and we want to do
the best that we can and I think we will
be putting a report to the executive
um scrutiny so that's the housing
associations to provide some more data
it did provide quite a lot of days but
we wanted to hear about
um since last year what progress have
been made and then they're going to set
out some data with regard to that and I
think that would be extremely helpful
I am
yeah I think
what what what I would say
that we it was a good meeting
um there seemed to be a spirit suit
cooperation
which helps
you know words and policies and I think
we all know this words and promises are
absolutely fine however what's really
important is action to deliver for the
people that we actually represent and
you know that's why we will continue to
try and do in scrutiny to to work with
them to to make that happen
thank you very much councilor Acton I
know all of us on the executive are very
grateful to the Opium scrutiny committee
for carrying out this important piece of
work it reflects back to a council
meeting we had in July where this this
matter came up and it's very important
that we continue to work with the local
housing providers and make sure
standards are high and thank you to
council right and to Adrian Fisher for
attending the the screw c meeting last
week
um councilor but do you have anything
you'd like to say today
we've had no further meeting since our
executive last week uh
thank you councilor but with that we
shall move on to 195 which is places for
everyone and I'll pass over to councilor
Ms Patel
thank you Tom before I start my
presentation of the report I think I
should make the except aware that we had
an email from Nathan Evans of the
conservative group yesterday afternoon
raising um what he described as flaws
concerns about the evidence base that
has been used to put forward places for
everyone and identifying what he felt
was a risk of judicial review as a
result of that I've got a few points to
make briefly in response and also a very
very detailed
um briefing that which I'm happy to
circulate to council Evans and Beyond
after the meeting so just um to sort of
summarize our response
um you should know that the risk of
challenge by way of judicial review can
never be eliminated the question we need
to ask is around the risk of any such
challenge being successful
and I can confirm that a very robust
process has been followed both at local
level and collaboratively across greater
Manchester
this process has had oversight as a
panel of independent inspectors
the process has included independent
examination hearings considering all
aspects of the plan indeed the initial
beginnings of the public examination
focused exclusively on the
evidence-based and the legality of that
um at the outset of the hearing
following that no serious flaws in the
evidence base underpinning the plan have
been identified and therefore the
executive can be confident that the risk
of successful challenge is minimal in so
far as the areas that we've covered in
the notes that we're going to circulate
so following that I'll
start my presentation in the report this
report to Executive tonight marks a
significant stage in the adoption of
places for everyone
strategic plans of nine of the greater
Manchester authorities that this
Administration continues to strongly
support as the best route to a
sustainable future for Trafford that we
are here today seeking approval to enter
the final stages of what has been a long
and difficult process is Testament to
the soundness of the plan and the huge
public interest there is in its adoption
places for everyone receives our support
because its implementation represents a
bold plan for sustainable regional
growth Which shapes the better future
for our communities tackles the housing
crisis head-on and invests in skills
jobs and productivity
it provides us locally with targets for
housing office and industrial floor
space which will inform our upcoming
local plan
it provides a robust strategic framework
of Environmental Protections including
nature restoration enhancing green and
blue infrastructure and significant
enhancement of biodiversity across GM
places for everyone will maintain a new
and defensible green belt which will
endure beyond the plan period
taking a regionally strategic approach
to growth or support to Greater
Manchester's Ambitions to be carbon
neutral with an expectation within the
plan that all new developments will be
Net Zero carbon by 2028.
since the last report to Executive the
plan has been through the process of
public examination LED independently by
three inspectors this process is
detailed further in the report
the role of these inspectors is to
determine whether the submitted plan
meets the test of soundness defined in
the National planning policy framework
this public examination process was
thorough professional independent fair
and transparent among many areas that
were covered were matters around the
legality of the plan environmental
assessments the allocation of green belt
how sustainable proposed new housing
locations are housing targets as well as
dedicated days on individual housing
allocations including New Carrollton and
timpley wedge
further additional days were convened to
consider deep peaty soil at a number of
sites including new counters all
interesting parties including those who
sought to raise objections were provided
with Fair access to the process and had
an opportunity to make their case all
sessions were recorded and remained
available to view online
it is usual for the outcome of a plan
examination to result in the inspectors
recommending a number of modifications
necessary to make the plan sound legally
compliant these modifications are
categorized as main or minor
modifications and for the purpose of
this proposed next step of consultation
it will be the responses to the main
modifications that are considered by the
planning inspectors
the public examination process was
robust and challenging and having gone
through the process in good faith it's
right that GM Partners accept the
outcomes
to Briefly summarize just some of the
main modifications
the inspectors have rejected a number of
the proposed new additions to the green
belt put forward by GM partners
two sites in Greater Manchester have
been removed from the plan and a small
number of amendments to allocation
boundaries have been made in Trafford
this includes a minor modification to
the timpley wedge screen belt boundary
there are no boundary changes for the
Carrington allocation have been proposed
removal of an overarching GM affordable
housing Target which has been replaced
with site-specific allocations
reflective of local needs and viability
specifically to Trafford this identifies
a minimum of 15 affordable housing at
new Carrington and a minimum of 45
affordable housing at Tivoli wedge
public examination has resulted in
additional policy requirements in
relation to Pete at new Carrington there
is a need for ideological and ground
investigation studies to inform the
master plan as well as suitable
compensation strategies where necessary
it is a rather complex report so that we
have included we have produced and
included a plain English version
alongside it
I would like to conclude by making a few
points about the green allocations
within places for everyone
an area that has come to dominate debate
to the extent in my opinion where it has
been detrimental to the overall
understanding of places for everyone
in the places for everyone Brownfield
and Urban Development will play the most
significant role in land identified for
development
one of the key questions posed at the
examination was whether too much or too
little land was being proposed for
release from the Green Belt to meet the
future development needs of Greater
Manchester
Greenbelt campaigners have taken a
narrow view on how future development
can be accommodated the council's
approach is to state that in order for
the right mix of homes and jobs to be
built in the future some green belt
release is necessary
the inspectors have considered this
question at length but have not
recommended significant changes in
response this shows that whilst
campaigners may still think too much
Greenbelt is being released the
examining inspectors don't agree
the campaigners have made their case and
have made detailed submissions in a
public forum but ultimately their
arguments didn't convince
the policies in places for everyone will
result result in the overall extent of
the nine authorities Green Belt reducing
by 4.1 percent
the policies in the places for everyone
plan will reduce the extent of land
designated as green belt across greater
Manchester from 47 to 45 percent in
Trafford the current adopted Green Belt
covers 37 of the borough the allocations
at new counting in temporary wedge will
reduce this to 35.1 percent
this Administration considers that this
is an acceptable ask of the green belt
in order to provide the land Supply
needed to address the housing crisis
to do this within the context of a
strategic plan provides a measured and
planned approach that protects against
speculative development on the green
belt in the future a pressure that we
would inevitably face if we sought to go
it alone and a subject we would have to
tackle instead within our local plan
finally I would like to thank officers
here in Trafford and at gmca who have
provided excellent support during the
examination process and continue to work
hard for the benefit of residents in
Greater Manchester this process has been
a showcase for the expertise and
dedication that we hold in local
government thank you
thank you councilman tell for that very
detailed and clear explanation of the
the paper that we see before us and I
also Echo your thanks to the officers
here for all the work that they have put
into this uh this huge um huge uh item
that we have before us I'd also like to
thank you though because Patel because
you have kept very close to this to
places for everyone throughout and I
know that you did take time out to look
at some of the hearings as they were
earlier this year and then took notes on
on what was being said there and finally
the um the detailed six-page briefing
note that you were alluded to at the uh
at the start in response to uh
represents read by councilor Evans very
grateful to have that level of assurance
there very grateful for the summary of
that that node that you put forward and
I feel assured by um the responses that
we've we've received to proceed to a
decision this evening
do we have any questions or comments
from Council Williams
but it's uh won't speak about just
closely to a code of things that
um
exposed to offices I know this has been
an extremely long journey
um in its original isolation as a
spatial framework and now
um and it's common form but I think we
are starting to see the realization of
that vision and concepts are widely
discussed
um uh the impact on the above this green
pill but I did just want to reflect on
the fact that in unlocking the
Carrington site for development we will
be able to see one of the largest single
Brownfield sites and create a Manchester
Unleashed for residential Housing
Development and I think that's
particularly welcome indeed and I've
spoken before the planet committee how
um I would like to see an approach that
almost always will prioritize at
Brownfield sites first so I I think this
is a good news story and I'm very happy
to support the recommendations thank you
Jennifer thank you councilor Williams
Council Wright
there is no doubt about that also as a
board counselor so you've got lotion for
obviously the current and allocation is
um
it's very fantastic to see the
developments in this part of the borough
and for the people in Boston to have a
real access to group jobs through the
creation of the character really for our
comparatively thank you Lena thank you
councilor right
any other questions or comments
okay I shall go to counselor Ennis first
of all
thank you John thank you Catholics help
for for giving the report there I want
to ask specifically about the affordable
quotas that you mentioned there members
of the exact will know better than most
at the 45 and 15 quotas respectively set
out in these plans are essentially
meaningless
parking for a moment the fact that
affordable quotas are too easy to get
around and that developers do so all the
time through viability assessments the
real issue has been because affordable
housing can be referred to as affordable
housing when it is 20 lower than the
average market rate in a given area so
in the case of typically wedge which
borders one of the most expensive
postcodes in the country and where the
average house price last year was
upwards of one million pound are we
really suggesting that 20 less than a
million pound constitutes affordable
housing in any meaningful sense of the
world and looking at the list of
community infrastructure commitments
that have been watered down or removed
as part of this modifications report it
really just reads like a blank check for
developers so how convinced is the
committee that traffic will get any
affordable housing at all our places for
everyone
Council Patel
I mean given the
exceptional Market circumstances he's
just outlined there in timpley you would
wonder why
um local politicians would somehow
object to a housing plan that would
deliver such tremendous amounts of
affordable housing it's I it you know I
know the live Dems really struggle with
them
uh developers but we don't need Trafford
and it's we approach viability
Assessments in Trafford extremely
robustly developers don't get around us
all the time to quote you
um
it in fact the 15 is an absolute minimum
in um new Carrington as well so the what
we class is it affordable will be a
whole range of offers and if we can work
with the social housing providers and
others to offer a whole range of
affordable housing
um we will do so
um we're going to take affordable
housing in
a typically worked extremely seriously
and robustly
absolutely thank you very much councilor
Patel councilor Paul
thank you chair and the thank you
Council Patel for the report
um it's quite an in-depth report uh
I'm referring especially to page 19
and I think that the report highlights
that we're still able to make changes to
this disastrous plan on building on
Cannington Moss
page 19 it is suggested there are no
realistic Alternatives I suggest that
there are as there always are
by making sure we have an up-to-date
local plan focusing on why residents
needs and concerns it appears labor in
traffic are only focused on concreting
on this white Supreme space which holds
this carbon capturing Peach Moss that
has done its job for the environment for
over a thousand years
Stockport has removed itself from the
developers Cash Card dream known as GMS
or sorry counselor
yes and I thought it was also for
questions and comments questions from
other parties yeah sure I suggest we do
the same
and I urge the sponsor to extend the
modification and consider withdrawing
from the plan is that something that can
be considered thank you councilor Paul I
mean Council for Telecaster I did
provide an answer to your question as
part of the informational theme for
they've given now introducing the paper
book Council to tell do you have
anything to ask we had a motion problem
from the terms and the conservative
group earlier this year asking us to
withdraw from places for everyone and
the answer is is no we're not going to
do that we're not going to revisit the
basic principles of the plan we're not
going to attempt to go It Alone
Stockport is no example to look for uh
look towards they are extremely
vulnerable and sitting outside
um you know this strategic approach to
GM
um won't play out very well for them so
we're well beyond that basic argument
now with Advanced this plan in the face
of huge organized political opposition
nationally and locally and we're
determined to see it through to its
adoption
thank you Council Patel councilor
Coggins
okay thank you Joe and thank you to um
Adrian and this team and all the
officers who I know I've got a lot of
work into this and I wanted to just
mention as I have often before on page
three the carbon reduction section at
the front we have discussed before the
cover reduction section is not a green
wash section where we can say all the
good things that are in the report and
ignore all the um challenging things we
know that places for everyone is talking
about doubling the use of the airport
over the next 20 years and and things
like that would you not mention there
and so first of all I'm supposed to be
masking for a recommitment to the
commitment I've had many times before
that the carbon reduction section and
these reports
um can be used as a more neutral
overview of the implications rather than
an opportunity to pick out any positives
while ignoring the negatives
uh that was that was one question and
some of my questions have been answered
um by um earlier comments
um
I I have some questions that have come
from the friends of Carrington Moss that
they've asked me to um pass on and some
of which again have been um answered as
well and particularly they were worried
about the affordable housing targets
being moved by the gmca they said from
the policy section to the reasons
justification section
um and they're worried that this
de-provertises the social housing
element and they're also concerned that
there remains no
um provision for the Gypsy Roma traveler
community and they're concerned about
the impact on the war really economy
both grade to farmland and and and
others and so I had two sets questions
thanks thank you councilor Coggins um
councilor Patel I'm happy and Friends of
Carrington Moss want to put those
detailed questions to us for us to sort
of take a detailed response to them
directly
um just quickly on you know the point
you have made several times about
environmental impact assessment and it's
a challenge to do on the whole of places
for everyone noting that each individual
stage has been subjected to quite
significant environmental impact
assessments and that's part for separate
appendices to to this
um so it will be difficult for us to
summarize that in the neat paragraph I
think in the front but it but it is
information that is available about
um the impact of places for everyone
proposals
um the removal of affordable
um houses but the inspectors of ofastia
to remove an overarching commitment to
affordable housing which was based on a
GM strategy
um uh which it didn't meet the sort of
evidence base that is required to fit
into a planning application but what it
does not do is in any way downgrade our
commitment to affordable housing within
the plan it just relates it to us to a
site-specific requirement
um which is as I've covered earlier in
the 15th minimum of 15 and 45 locally so
it it's a sort of a technical Point
um that to reassure friends of character
Moss that hasn't downgraded or the
affordable housing aspirations
um
the Traveler's Point um I could get back
to you on that I know locally we are
going to be looking at that within our
local plan I know we're trying to
identify land before that
um the the idea of the US damaging the
rural economy and that was all covered
you know aspects of Economic Development
and how the sites have been identified
and whether they're sustainable or
covered by by the public examination
um
that area of traffic just sit within the
Trafford economy and we're aware of that
and um
we don't believe that there's any
specific risks to sort of economic
activity in that area because of it
thank you councilman councilor for us
thank you later uh I wanted to focus
perhaps also a bit different on the
flood risk assessment work as typically
wages Upstream of timpley itself so
changes that can impact simply North uh
which obviously Downstream I was looking
at the composite volatile document
there's quite a lot of references in
that to vital flooding prevention work
which appeared to have been struck
through so obviously if you've got like
more hard surfaces from houses driveways
roofs roads you're going to get that
speed of runoff aren't you and on
multiple occasions in the last few years
having rainfalls led to houses getting
flooded and insurance claims in my ward
but in 16-3 that's a huge paragraph uh
there's points or 43 44.5 that talk
about on-site measures to control runoff
but they've been struck off there's a
paragraph about actively reducing the
impact of flood risk and that's deleted
so what's my question well I'm just
concerned how can we as a council accept
those kind of changes when in July 2022
this Council voted for motion 11 as it
was on the agenda then 11a which was
specifically about the Watercourse that
runs through this site we've been
promised long-term flood mitigation in
this sort of development on temporary
wage and the council voted last year to
work together towards a flooding
resilience goals but then paragraph 1191
says Downstream there's existing flood
risks places for Everyone's an
opportunity to help her and that one's
being deleted so I'm just I'd just like
you to talk a bit about in light of the
previous votes we've had which were
unanimous I think how can we accept
those kind of edits going forward just
interested in that okay thank you very
much Council fast before I bring me in
Council so I I was just going to mention
the integrated Water Management plan
that is uh is currently being sat with
the combined Authority it's under my
remits at uh the gmca it is a
partnership between United utilities the
environment agency the combined
Authority and it will grow it's one of
the first of its kind in the country and
very much part of it we'll be looking at
sustainable development managing flood
risk
um so it's well I know it's been
scrutiny or it's about to grow too
exclusive a combined Authority level but
yeah there'll be more information on
that and how that works with development
but I'm going to pass over
I'm happy to reassure councilor for us
that um the flood risk um mitigation
offer has not in any way been downgraded
at Tinley wedge what's happened
um during the public examination is that
a number of duplicated policies
um from within individual allocation and
summaries have been removed so that's
the lines through it so to to remove
duplication and make the plan read is
read easier they are summarized in a GM
wide policy within places for everyone
so nothing has been watered down or
removed it's simply being it's almost an
administrative thing that they've made
it a more concise read by
setting out in the GM policy
thank you Council so and Council Bluffs
well thank you I've just got to a four
very short questions just a bit context
but uh
those toys actually on the modifications
for the plan which is about three sorry
inspectors only to consider main mods
for soundness and legal compliance uh
but they have no power to recommend
other changes or even if they will
improve the plan so the question on that
one is does that mean the council would
not consider those improvements possible
in the days of became apparent for us
question one uh the other one is uh mods
to traffic allocations which is power
five and that is a mixed reference to
ground studies relating to Peak deposits
at character loss and suitable
compensation strategies when appropriate
I'm just wondering can you elaborate on
what they might be
the question please the global homes
which is uh traffic deal that's
effectively the one which is 40 15
affordable uh in Carrington and 45 on
the typical wage just wondering the uh
why the big sort of discrepancy that is
a particular reason
what that is
uh I know he elaborated on some of that
too so if you can skip that particular
point and final one is to lose weight
and power 9 which is to look at the
consultation and to do with jobs it
states that responses from the gmsf 2019
called suspension we used to inform the
current PSE plan and the same year that
kobit 19 pandemic struck so there has
been a huge change in Employment
Practices since then many would say
reversible changes I've been working
becomes a normal indeed Expectations by
employees as well uh and employers to
downsize their own disabilities reduce
cost submissions and all these things so
a huge amount of workspace are now
awaken across UK and many are being
connected to Apartments the question is
uh why is traffic a job is floor space
Target can be increased to 223
661 square meters or uh Timberly wage
and the county moss in the plants
thank you
um I think the point about
Improvement
um
it just really outlines the role of the
inspectors in the sense that they they
don't take an active role in developing
and suggesting policies within the plan
does that mean that GM hasn't um sort of
advice far and wide and consulted on and
considered how to
formulate the plan no
um so I don't know I think you've sort
of cross-referenced her GM's ears
haven't been closed
um to suggestions around this the
development of this policy and the peak
deposits
um we know more in the last 12 months
than ever before about
about the nature location of peak
deposits on um new Carrington
um it was uh two additional days were
convened at the public examination on
this matter and as a result I think one
site was taken out
um I think it was a Salford site was
removed from the plan because of it
um as with all development on places for
everyone that they will all be required
to undertake much more detailed
environmental um surveys and in the case
of a new Carrington that includes
surveys around Pete although we won't
know the exact extent of that until
development comes forward in the master
planning process
um comes forward it I would just sort of
like to say that
the the reference to sort of Carrington
Moss isn't reflective of a of an extent
of large deep Peak reserves right across
the site it fluctuates tremendously
um and
um the area of deep heat and resides in
this more in the center of the site and
and we will have to master plan
accordingly around that
um the discrepancy in the
um or the difference in the um
affordable housing requirements are
reflected on reflected of the the
viability of the site so some areas in
New Carrollton are heavily contaminated
and will take a great deal of
remediation to bring it up to develop
those standards some places in template
wedge or in new Carrington indeed will
be a lot more straightforward in
development terms and whereas that when
that the case will be pressing for a
higher percentage of affordable housing
provision so in New Canton it's a
minimum of 15 but that could extend up
to 45
in some areas where we do that um it's
easier a more straightforward to
development develop I think the current
um
affordable housing requirement in that
area of new Carrington is around five
percent so it is it is an improvement
but it generally just reflects um
a viability of sites as they come
forward the impact of covid was
considered
um in great detail in places for
everyone and that has had that is
reflected in um the provision of office
space within Trafford I can't to hand
find that number
um Adrian fish did send me an email
detailed email on that I think our
office provision has gone down in our
warehousing and Industrial provision has
gone up as a result of what we
understand from the changes in working
practice following covid but I'm happy
to get back to
more detail
thank you okay I am taking two more
questions of both have indicators so I'm
going to go to uh Council Weston first
of all because you can come up to a
microphone
thank you I'm I raised this question as
there is a particular concern in
Wolverton uh emboded walls is the
Council planning on working with retro
pumps on any of this default provision
and I'm mostly referring to the possible
Reviving of the Retro plans in Wolverton
Parish an area adjacent to South
Parkington for perhaps 400 homes
previous Ambitions were lost at appeal
with 10 reasons given for refusal a key
well-being lack of affordable housing
provision and clearly that's a key
element of bigquery so it's a council
minded to explore retro Avenues on this
occasion can I ask thank you thank you
Council Matson
um I've Red Road I believe were present
at the um
examination or represented there amongst
our house of the audience and I would
ask is it um
for
for Richard to come in on the specifics
there and as with all house builders
volume house builders we will have to
work with them on the sites and that
come forward but we'll
um
get back to you specifically on that one
so that particular site lands out the
parts into is the land that's identified
within places for everyone far
development uh retro will understand
they have a an option on the land that
they did
a planning application previously which
was rejected at the council's decision
was upheld appeal subject to PSE uh
being adopted in due cast and my drove
would be able to submit a new
application but we'll need to do that in
accordance with the principles are set
out in places for everyone and also in
accordance with council's adopted
planning policies
and thank you very much rich thank you
Council and the last question will be
from councilor Duncan councilor if you
could come up to the microphone
ask a question
yeah yeah thank you chat
um is it what council for manager a huge
consents not just in manager but
neighboring Awards as well
um
a couple of questions have been answered
however on behalf of big friends at
Council Moss
um out of the 5000 homes just 750 have
been allocated for affordable
that's actually quite shocking but I'm
sure Council Patel you've said that can
increase to 45 so thank you for
answering that and with regards to job
Creations councilor
um right mentioned jobs before
um looking at the plans a lot of the uh
construction
uh shovels in the ground would be
relating to workhousing so residents of
uh are wanting to know
potentially are approximately how many
jobs could be created by this potential
build and also finally
um can you see
um where is the preliminary uh
ecological appraisal for new character
thank you very much thank you thank you
councilor Duncan
um councilor Patel thank you just to
clarify
um our new Carrington the affordable
housing begins at a minimum of 15 but
could go higher
um depending on the viability of the
plots coming forward
um and I don't know about the
warehousing job numbers but I'm happy to
get attract you on that the question
about the preliminary
environmental assessment you mentioned
was the subject of councilor evans's
email inquiry and I'm happy to circulate
a um a detailed note to members in
answer to that question
thank you councilor Patel so
clearly this was going to raise a lot of
questions it is a very big piece of work
for the borough as I said originally so
it was going to generate a lot of
questions and I'm very very grateful to
councilor Patel for the amount of
detailed responses that she's provided
over the course of the last half hour
thank you very much for that
um in summary
this paper provides an update on the
examination stage and modifications to
the plan and those modifications are now
subject to a consultation relevant
representations will be considered by
the inspectors post consultation and
prior to finalizing the examination
report
and just a reminder has been said a
couple of times today that not
progressing with places for everyone
would likely require traffic to deliver
a higher housing number and release of
more green belt which is why it's so
important that we take this next step to
this evening so the recommendations are
set out as one to three in the paper for
those in favor
thank you very much now if we move on to
item six which is the poverty strategy
recess refresh and uh councilor James
Wright
thank you leader um excuse me firstly
I'd like to say how do they divide that
to take responsibility for the poverty
strategy
this musical year most people in this
room will know how passion assembly
server they are to read poverty from the
lives of everyone is foreign
policy in the very front of our
priorities and will continue to do so
poverty is real a lack of money affects
your mental and physical health it
dominates your thoughts and it affects
each and every part of you no one in
Trafford you'd have to use your food
bank and that is why I will continue to
work with others I should Cuts first a
cash first approach not just is it the
right thing to do it's also what people
have experienced ones is also exactly
what the country's largest Food Bank
Network the trust of trust is
campaigning for
the public policy strategy is a
two-minute strategy jointly developed by
Apartments to prevent reduce and
ultimately work for any poverty and
Trafford a poverty strategy has been
developed in Partnership to incorporate
the work of the traffic poverty truth
Commission
the tourism commission run from May 27
till March 23 brought together Community
Commissioners and Civic Commissioners
from across Stratford
throughout the project they work
together as a former relationships
explore the causes of poverty and the
facts and to develop ideas for how we
can come together as communities
the work including the publication of
the property Transmissions
recommendation reforms in March 23. the
recommendations problems reports have
been embedded into the 23 to 25 strategy
the strategy is still focused around the
five things developed in Partnership
for the previous version work with the
BTC there's been intertwined into these
previous themes and the new strategy
also has a stronger focus on the
importance of listings and voices of
those who lived experience
these five things these are actions to
tackle the causes of poverty and to help
raise our residents out of poverty I
would also like to thank
you to Claire and Kate and all the other
Commissioners including Diana sat next
to my life for all that out of hard work
on this the majority of my thanks of
course goes to people who don't want
their time to talk to us about those
experience of poverty in traffic
the recommendations report the report
right ask the executive to approve the
traffic poverty strategy and the work of
the traveling property through the
commission thank you
thank you councilor right and once again
I would like to Echo your face
particularly for all the work that went
on around the property approved
commission and I know that Council Patel
was involved in that other members of
the executive were heavily involved in
that important piece of work and I think
that we've all learned a lot from
listening to uplift experience do we
have any questions or comments from the
members of the executive Council Harding
thank you later and as the former
executive member who um had
responsibility for the poverty strategy
last year
um this is one of the most important
pieces of work that this Council can
continue to build on it's also
incredibly important to listen to the
voices of our residents who will
continue to tell us about their
experiences of poverty and as Council
the right stated poverty is real it's
real for people in work too we've seen
an increase of people within work
poverty I just wanted to draw members
attention to the kerslake report that
came out today that talks about the
government's Target to end rough
sleeping by 2024 is more or less Spanish
and the fact that homelessness has gone
up by 26 percent I just think this ties
in with the previous report that we have
just discussed really
and it states many unresolved issues
um systemic issues one of them being a
severe shortage of affordable housing
coupled with the cost of living crisis
which is indeed a perfect storm the
housing Minister has insisted that this
government remains committed to eroding
homelessness and that homelessness is a
priority but there are three main
strategies outlined in the report that's
about preventing people becoming
homeless in the first place ensuring
that nobody needs to end up on the
streets and that everybody should have a
route out of homelessness so really I
just wanted to draw members attention to
that report I think the previous report
we've discussed and the the poverty
strategy mentions housing and
homelessness and all of those wraparound
services so thank you to officers and
all of the residents that have continued
to contribute to this incredibly
important strategy thank you
thank you councilor Harding yes you can
see how things all join up in the work
that we do Council Carter
uh thank you chair
um I want to Echo what Joe said about
um sorry councilor Harding about how
much we welcome this new strategy and um
I'm certainly glad to see that children
young people are privatized in our
property strategy
um I know the exec know that we're fully
committed to providing children with the
best start in life through our best
Beginnings board which focuses on
Bridging the Gap in the early years
through the rollout of our family hubs
and ensuring the first
1001 critical day highlights any
challenges at the earliest point
we're also providing scrutiny of
outcomes for our most disadvantaged
pupils which will be carried out with
schools during our quality assurance
visits with the specific aim of
supporting schools to close the
attainment gap and we are supporting
more families through early intervention
and support from services such as
healthy child program parenting support
mental and emotional health services
finally we will continue to deliver the
offset Improvement plan to continue to
improve outcomes for children young
people in Trafford to raise as many
families as we can out of poverty and we
really welcome this report thank you
to help and housing income and energy
life changes or people have actually
touch yourself especially like this is
so important not against because
in particular and I really like that you
look on the earth
support and all the groups and there's
something that's about totally opposite
I think it's a the next two years before
it's actually how we can actually think
about this actually
which I think is so important
thank you Council I said it is why we're
all here on this table isn't it any
questions from any of us
customers
thank you um the green group would like
to
say thank you to everybody who's been
involved in this
all the organizations
outside the council that further than
this as well it's great to see the
property truth commission for
recommendations included here
um it's a great very big piece of work
there's lots of aspects to it but I just
wanted to reflect on the uh points three
and four of the property commission
recommendations that have that are in
here
um
regarding improving public transport
and tackling social isolation it's great
to see the doorstep destination is is
included in there so it's not just on
the transport itself but how he gets to
that public transport
um but also you know in terms of mental
tackling mental and socialization
there's lots of reports out there that
tell us that that you know people who
live on busy fast roads know up to 70
fewer people have fewer muscular social
interactions and I wonder how can we you
know how can we capture that you know in
our work in our policy development work
in the consultations we have on our
things like our transport projects
um when but whether they're you know
hopefully helping with that kind of
thing like an active travel project or
if we're trying to mitigate the harmful
impacts that maybe a major road scheme
for example could have
um on people's isolation
Council rights
uh yeah thank you uh Council Nelson for
the question obviously
um as a wallpaper for the problem is
most isolated thoughts before it's quite
useful for me to be answering this I
suppose
um just in relation to you're absolutely
Rising relation to isolation and uh
enabling the people to get from their
home to their required destination by
public transport and actually that's why
I think that the heritage of relief for
any advice for that part of the borough
because
um bosses have to travel on a road I'm
at the moment the road was there he
loved it for purpose and doesn't provide
people New Living parties and with the
opportunities to gain and get to that
employment that he does for everyone
else so frankly that particular role
actually benefits them greatly from that
perspective to be able to get onto a bus
and access the gym the good jobs that
are available in traffic on elsewhere
thank you thank you I mean it's very
timely talking about public transport
with the launch of the B Network which
formerly took place today and although
it's not yet come to traffic we're going
to be uh impacted mainly by the changes
in January 2025 it will give us as a
greater control over the services that
are out there and the more we can do to
make buses in particular in this example
accessible to people and affordable to
people the better it helps people's
Chances with life it helps in terms of
addressing isolation and I think it's
you know it's very tiny that that has
happened today as a little facts that
can help alleviate property
any other questions uh councilor Ennis
thank you lead I'll be brief I just
really want to welcome this work and
congratulate everyone that's been
involved with it on behalf of the global
Democrat group
um one of the real lifelines that came
out during the pandemic was the were the
local pubs
um I know we all will have stories and
examples of that being the case
certainly in my world that is there in
broomwood that is a real Lifeline still
and in specifically in relation to the
work that's been mentioned about
financial support and getting that
advice and resources into the right
place it just it members of the
community might want to talk a little
bit about the future role of local hubs
going forward and how that might
continue
that's all right
thanks for the question is the vast
majority of our thought is currently uh
provided equality on the household
support fund which obviously comes
direct from government we are very much
um we are very committed to community
homes uh going forward and we'll now be
part of the discussion group uh on
Thursday so coming Thursday probably
call
um what we really need from government
is some Assurance to go for the funding
related to the household support fund
um the um the the room if the room isn't
to be correct I am I am if he's
understood that they Council support
from well continued in what guys that is
going to be we'll have to wait and see
um but it has become a vital
um part of funding for things such as
this so I I urge I urge conservative
members in the head tonight to encourage
their government to continue that
funding and increase it preferably
because the more we can get the better
the internet poverty thank you
thank you Council rights and councilor
books yeah thank you Jay
um I'd just like to also welcome reports
being heard it's quite comprehensive and
uh I think the the quality staff 2010
seems to the books the minds of world
councils and I look forward to further
iterations
thank you thank you very much for that
so
um clearly supporting people out at
poverty remains a very important part of
our corporate plan and it's also clear
that this refresh Builds on the
excellent work undertaken by trafford's
poverty truth commission and it's been
incorporated into the commission's
recommendations
um we strive to improve our residents
living in property access Services we
want to make the voice of lived
experience part of trafford's way of
working we want to look to improve
public transport and we want to tackle
mental health and isolation in addition
to the current names we had as part of
the strategy so it is really welcome
refresh clearly there are a lot of
people suffering out there and as a
local Council we want to do our bids to
try and address the causes of poverty
and poverty itself the recommendations
are to note this refresh and note that a
further update will be provided by the
property strategy in 2023-25 all those
thank you very much if we move on now to
the equality strategy update and I'll
pass over to councilor campaigns
thank you very much leader and I think
my report this evening
um also really well done tables with two
previous reports actually and this is
the
um the equality strategy update I am
really pleased to bring this update this
evening and I would like to thank Diane
Geary and Adele coin and who have been
instrumental in this piece of really
important work and also councilman
Slater and who this work began
um which is in that role and so members
will recall that the equality strategy
was launched in January 2021 and it
continues to be a tremendous piece of
work and which demonstrates our
commitment to improve inequality
opportunity
um as councilor ads had was just talking
about and for all our residents our
colleagues and our partners and this
report provides the fourth progress
update on achievements since the
strategy was launched and since the
previous update report which was um in
January this year there have been some
uh key highlights which I just wanted to
mention so the equality working group
has successfully increased the number of
um equality Champions and so that each
director is now represented and members
of the equality working group have
produced a zero tolerance statement and
and that's with input and comments from
colleagues across the council the
purpose of that statement is to inform
all customers clients and visitors that
the council has zero tolerance approach
to dealing with incidents of abusive and
behavior towards our staff and will take
action if
be a corporate anti-racism policy for
dealing with incidents of racial abuse
is currently being
finalized and this is to ensure that a
robust policy is in place for dealing
with inserts incidents towards staff
from other staff or from clients and
customers and in March the executive
approved the proposal for the term
ethnically diverse communities to be
used in the council's documents and
Publications and this was the um clear
preferred term
um when we did consult and in June
Trafford commemorated the 75-year wind
Rush anniversary and that included an
event following the Calypso Legend Lord
Kitchener whose real name
um was Baldwin Roberts and then he had
lived in Stratford and there is a blue
plaque and which was unveiled at house
in Stratford and also in June the
council promoted a care this week and
which recognized and supporting carers
and the leader met with Trafford deaf
partnership in July and where the
members of the partnership were able to
share their achievements and their lived
experience and to help advise on how
best support facilities
and and to ensure full access to
services and working with Trafford
Leisure and primary care and to
implement the physical activity referral
scheme and this provides low-cost access
to Leisure centers and community
activities and work has commenced
leading as stakeholders group to ensure
that the redevelopments of Parsons and
Leisure Center
um via the letter will not performed
addresses Health inequalities and to
date just over a thousand staff members
have completed the quality Essentials
and equality and diverse diversity
module training and so those are just
some highlights from the report book
members will see that it is a really
comprehensive update on the strategy and
I'm really pleased and to finish report
this evening recommendations are set out
in the report I ask members to approve
and to note those again thank you
councilor Hines
um councilor Carter
thank you and um I really welcome this
report and one of the things that
counselor Hines missed out was that
members will remember in March we had
care experience people recognize as a
characteristic
um just to inform members that the young
people then came to the corporate
parenting board and said well what does
this mean for us when so which is
completely and utterly valid question
and we welcomed it so we're in the
process of
um getting some documentation together
so that young people know exactly what
that does mean and how and we intend to
support our care experience young people
at least till the age of 25 but probably
um further than that so thank you for
this report the council lines
and um helps us later thank you later
and I'm very welcome
and thanks for all the hard work that's
been undertaken since I was prized away
and they would like to thank and
since 2021 when the instructory was
introduced and Trafford it wasn't
something that we had prior to and the
labor labor Administration taking
control of
it's really important and the strategy
fits to every aspect of our priorities
across across the board you know from
the property strategies and housing to
keep you well at home all those things
it covers absolutely everything and I'm
just really proud of the hard work
that's gone on in there and I can't wait
to look through it and thank you
thank you councilor Slater and it goes
about saying I express my thanks for all
the work that you did on this strategy I
know it was very very difficult to uh to
to pass it over to CAF but it's in safe
hands of class ICS thank you any other
questions from anyone uh councilor
welcome
thank you again
awful lot of work that's that's going on
so it's good to see that all in one
place I just one thing that I I didn't
see anything about was the Town Center
accessibility audience that took the
place
two nearly two years now we're going out
and I'm just wondering you know will we
see reference to those and and some
future work going on as a result of
those those audits in a future report
thank you
yeah thank you and that is a really
um valid question actually and yes we
will see updates and I don't know that
we've got an update to bring at the
moment actually and that's that's
probably why because this is the update
report but it was really important piece
of work and I attended
um one of those sessions actually on and
you are right so I think we'll probably
our due to bring
um an update on that thank you
yes I think I also attended a session
with uh with with cancer Slater to talk
about a year ago now so yeah we
interactive for that is to see what's
happened with that so uh councilor
Taylor
yes thank you I welcome the report as
somebody who's a member of the most
ethically diverse Council group in any
attempt to stand part of racism or
anything else we absolutely welcome
because it's disgraceful and I do want
to thank Adele and Diane Geary for all
the work that they've put in and it's
just amazing that we can do stuff like
this in the council So yeah
thank you
any of her questions uh councilor but
okay
um yeah we welcome this just wanted to
make a point on pilot 2.5 anti-listen
policy for dealing with incidents of
racial abuse is currently being
finalized I understand yeah and it
mentions staff on customers but does not
include members who are found in my own
case
it does not address the issue in a
reverse way
so it's good to know that in in extreme
out of 52 there is reference to Quality
objective one or uptake of training on
mandatory EDI course which states
equality is everybody's business for all
staff I think that should also include
members
thank you councilor but I think that is
um an important comment and we'll seek
to take that forward thank you
thank you
um I don't know if there's any other
questions
um
goes without saying a huge thanks for me
to spoke Diane Geary and to Adele as
well for the sheer amount of work they
uh put into into this strategy and
liaising with the different groups that
we have and I know that they work
incredibly hard to make people's lives
better across the borough so thank you
from all of us in the executive the
report as councilor Heisman is
incredibly
wide-reaching it shows the scope of of
equality and how important it is to each
and every one of us to get it right and
yeah I take on board what council Court
says yes we are very much should be
embedded as counselors in that as well
so we'll take that away
um so we are recommended to note the
report and also note further updates all
those in favor
thank you so I have no urgent business
so we're going to go on to the exclusion
resolution once again so I shall Now
read that out that the public be
excluded from this meeting during
consideration of the remaining items on
the agenda because of the likelihood
disclosure of exempt information which
Falls within one or more descriptive
category or categories of the Local
Government Act 1972 schedule 12a as
amended by the local government access
to information variation order 2006 and
specified on the agenda item or report
relating to each such item respectively
I almost say that in my sleep now Alex
are we um are we clear
that's right